اليوم مقابلة جديدة مع كامالا هاريس
وسؤال مألوف ولكن إجابة
تحمل عواقب إضافية هذه المرة
هل أنت مستعد لتكون
القائد الأعلى نعم أنا كذلك إذا لزم الأمر
ولكن جو بايدن سيكون على ما يرام
واسمحوا لي أن أخبرك بشيء  أنا أعمل مع
جو بايدن كل يوم، إن
العمل الذي أنجزته إدارتنا تحت قيادة جو بايدن
هو عمل تحويلي. أعتقد أن
الشعب الأمريكي يريد أكثر من أي شيء آخر
زعيمًا ينجز الأمور بالفعل، لقد
عادت لجنتي معي الآن، ما
رأيك في هذه الإجابة  وعلى نطاق أوسع، كيف
تتشكل ليكون لها
دور في إعادة الانتخاب، من
الواضح أن أه هاريس تريد الإذعان
لبايدن وتعزيز حجة
هذه الإدارة بأنه
حيوي وقادر على الوظيفة في نفس الوقت  من
الواضح أيضًا أنه يريد تخفيف
المخاوف من أن المرشحين الجمهوريين
يحاولون الدفع بأن
إدارة هاريس ستكون أسوأ من
إدارة بايدن ولكن هناك أيضًا
توتر أه أن حديث هاريس عن
هذا على الإطلاق رأيناه في استطلاعاتنا
اليوم وبشكل عام ذلك  هناك
ديمقراطيون آخرون في الحزب
يفضلون شخصًا آخر غير هاريس
لخلافة بايدن، ولا ينبغي لنا أن
نتفاجأ بوجود سياسيين
يريدون أن يصبحوا الرئيس القادم
للولايات المتحدة وساسة ديمقراطيون،
وهذا ما يحدث جميعًا.  في ذلك الوقت،
لكن كون هاريس نائبة
الرئيس الحالية ليست الخيار الفعلي هو أمر
يدل على ثقة الحزب بها،
وصحيح أن
المرشحين الجمهوريين، وعلى وجه التحديد نيكي هالي،
يهاجمون بلا هوادة
فكرة أن كامالا هاريس يمكن أن تكون
رئيسة و  أنت لا تريد أن
تتمكن من القيام بذلك بطريقة
لا يستطيع معظم منافسيها القيام بها لأنها امرأة حتى
تتمكن من تقديم هذه الحجة وهي
تقوم بذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا كنت
معها في نيو هامبشاير هذا الأسبوع  لقد
فعلت ذلك وانظر إلى ما يمثله هذا بالفعل
وكيلًا لأه أن الرئيس بايدن
قديمًا وأن هناك ليبراليين، لذا فإن هناك
الكثير مما يحدث هنا ولكن أه ليس هناك
شك في أن نائب الرئيس هو في
مركز الاهتمام من جميع
الجوانب المختلفة الآن هناك
سؤال أيضًا إذا قمت بذلك وإذا
كان هناك مرشح آخر
ليحل محل الرئيس بايدن بطريقة أو بأخرى وهو أمر
لن يحدث، فهي لا تزال
الشخص الرائد في هذا السباق وهي
نائبة رئيس الولايات المتحدة، لذلك
أعتقد أن هذا هو أنت  نعرف كل
المناقشات التي دارت في واشنطن حول كيف
لا ينبغي لنا أن نرتقي إلى مستوى الأشياء،
فهناك أشخاص
في البلاد ناخبون أمريكيون من أصل أفريقي،
وناخبون آخرون يرغبون في
رؤية المزيد منها، لذا سواء أعجبها
ذلك أم لا، سنفعل ذلك  رؤية المزيد من
بلدها
الأجنبية